(birds chirping)
- [Mathew Portell] We understand
the effects of adverse childhood
experiences nationally.
This is not an issue that is
just isolated to my
demographic in my school.
You're gonna do great aren't you?
Okay, nice work.
We understand what it does to them
now and potentially in the future.
We're right off of downtown Nashville
and we're in the midst of some serious
transformation in gentrification.
And so a lot of our students
are being displaced.
We have students who are currently
experiencing some serious
tragedy in their lives.
And we know their stories and we take
a proactive approach here to make sure
their needs are being met.
Doing all right today?
The old approach was you're at school
you need to be at school and play school.
And it was compliance driven.
But the trauma approach
is taking a completely different lens.
They have to feel safe,
they have to feel nurtured
and they have to feel supported.
(children talking)
(child singing)
When kids walk through the door
they don't leave everything
that has happened at the door.
They're still developing emotionally,
they're still developing cognitively.
And we want to give them
the ability to do that
in a safe environment that is school.
To be quite frank, this transformation
is more about adults than it is kids.
- You had a perfect day?
- [Mathew Portell] It's
about giving the teachers
the understanding and support to be able
to meet the needs of the
kids on a basic level.
- One, two, three, four, five six.
There was a big mind
shift, for me especially.
My students might have had a bad day
something happened at home,
no one was home last night.
You can't just be like
come in and do math now.
So, when they know you can trust you
and they can talk to you,
their academics start to blossom.
- [Mathew Portell] One of the most
transformative strategies
is getting someone
who is trained in understanding
students mental health needs.
- I was brought in as part
of the district initiative
to increase the awareness
and knowledge of ACES,
which are adverse childhood experiences.
Class been okay?
- Yep
- So coming in and identifying different
trauma informed practices that we
can implement here in the school.
- [Mathew Portell] One of the foundational
programs that we're utilizing
is The Leader in Me.
A lot of people are very familiar
with The Seven Habits of Highly
Effective People for Kids.
And so here we foundationally
teach our kids the seven habits.
- You'll see the posters around the school
and you'll see the kids, they
know all of the seven habits.
And they will spout them out to you.
- The seven habits has helped me
because I had to put first things first.
I had to make sure that
I was getting good grades
and not starting drama with any kids.
- [Mathew Portell] We
also build the students
capacity to develop the leadership skills
by giving them a class in leadership.
It's part of our specials rotations.
Kindergarten through fourth grade
are part of The Leader in Me curriculum.
- ♪ Be proactive, be proactive ♪
- We share this common language.
It is so amazing with putting
everybody on the same page.
Building that positive school culture
in an environment where
everyone feels empowered to be successful.
- [Mathew Portell] We
now have students leading
other students in different activities
throughout the building.
- Who wants to go first?
- [Mathew Portell] And we value that.
- Good morning leaders,
the time is eight o'clock.
- Traditionally in most schools
you've got the iridescent lighting
that burns their eyeballs like laserbeams.
But here we have teachers who
use a lot of low lighting.
Some of our rooms have calming colors,
utilizing color as a strategy.
We also use essential oil diffusers
with just understanding
that your body is sensory.
We utilize mindfulness as a strategy
in understanding that smells
and things around you are helpful.
One of the approaches that
we're using are peace corners.
- A peace corner is like, a place
where you can just chill out.
If I get like, really
frustrated and feel like
I'm gonna yell or when I feel really sad,
about to cry I go to the peace corner.
- [Mathew Portell] It's
a proactive approach.
And so many times we give kids strategies
but we don't give them a time or a place
to practice those strategies.
(students talking)
- We've really put a lot of effort
in building positive relationships.
Under that there are strategies,
and one of them is our check
in and check out system.
- [Emily Chadwick] Hey Mariah
- Hi
- Ready to have another great day today?
- Yep
- Awesome
- My check in, check out buddy,
her name is Mariah and
she's in fourth grade.
She comes to see me at the beginning
and at the end of every day.
What are your goals for today?
- Listen, be on task and nice
- Awesome
She has three goals
everyday that she works on.
She can get zero, one of two points
for each of her goals.
- And then at the end of the
day, they know where they are.
How was your day?
- Good.
Actually it was fantastic.
- Fantastic?
People will see point sheets
but the most motivating piece
of our check in and check out system
is the mentor/mentee relationship.
- You go to him and he
asks about your day.
And if you had a problem somewhere,
we'll talk about that and
see how you can fix it.
- The child knows everyday
they come in this building
that somebody's excited
to see them in the morning
and excited to see them
right before they leave.
So do you think you can
knock that out of the park?
- Mmhm
- That's what I'm talking about.
And it's that positive
in, positive out mindset.
- You did it with me.
- That's right no but
you did it on your own.
That's you my man, nice work.
That's been a huge success.
Last year was a tough
year, it was really tough.
We didn't have the support systems
fully in place that we have now.
I didn't support teachers in
the way that I should have
and could have because
I was a new principal
and I just didn't know how.
But that all changed
at the end of the year
when we all just as a
team sat down and said
we've gotta do something different.
Our paradigm has to shift
where we're talking about not only
how to support students but
how to support yourself.
Self care.
- We know you can't help
others until you help yourself.
Sometimes this job is hard,
this job is exhausting.
Sometimes you just need a minute.
(keyboard tapping)
Tap in, tap out is something
that we've developed.
You can text someone and be like,
hey can you cover my class,
can you give me a second.
And we will gladly cover one another.
You sometimes just need to ask for help.
And it's okay and it's
really accepted here,
and it's promoted.
- This is gray.
- That's gray?
- [Mathew Portell] Operating in
trauma informed approach is a
blanketed approach for all kids.
- You all have done outstanding work.
- [Mathew Portell] We have to be able to
help them manage their
experiences in productive ways.
- What's your favorite on there.
- [Mathew Portell] It's
not compliance driven,
It's a we've got your back approach.
(birds chirping)